congressman Matt Gaetz represents the
state of Florida he watched carefully
today he joins us tonight so if you were
to sum up what we learned today from
these hearings and they were touted
throughout the day is pivotal a
bombshell an IAD a blowtorch what would
be your summary Donald Trump is
skeptical of foreign aid and permanent
Washington love's foreign aid because it
allows politicians and ambassadors and
government bureaucrats to do our
favorite thing give away other people's
money the Donald Trump was especially
concerned about the Ukraine because it
was the third most corrupt country in
the world and of course everyone in
permanent Washington wants you to
believe that Russia is always our enemy
and Ukraine is always our friend when
the reality is far more complex than
that Republicans did their best work
today when they drove a wedge between
that which Gordon someone presumed in
his wisdom as sort of part of the
diplomatic world and that which he
actually heard and saw and I think that
Mike Turner John Radcliffe Jim Jordan
did a great job showing that the only
direction that ambassador Solomon got
from President Trump is that President
Trump didn't want anything he just
wanted szalinski to fulfill the
commitments in his campaign to clean up
that country but you know what it just
didn't sit well with permanent
Washington and that's why the show goes
on so so that I mean would you say that
that's that's really the takeaway that
this is a debate about policy cloaked in
a lot of high-minded language designed
to sort of hide the ball from the rest
of us but it's really they don't like
what Donald Trump wants to do with
American policy toward Ukraine and
Russia it is the worst kind of
groupthink that I hear this show is an
enemy of and I think in Sandlin you see
another element of Washington emerged
sometimes people speak with the
president you know a couple times and
then all of a sudden they get the sense
that all of their own beliefs are then
the president's beliefs and that they
can go and say well because I have
surmised some conclusion on the global
stage and because some weeks ago I spoke
to the president I can say oh in fact
you know it is my belief that this ought
to be the case from the administration
standpoint the reality is far different
I think in Gordon Sandlin you see
someone who was an inner meddler who was
a bit out of his Lane and someone who
never
ever got direction from the President or
anyone else in the administration to
engage in a quid pro quo for aide and
the media what they do is they try to
conflate what someone's feelings are or
their what their belief is about policy
with what they actually observed and
what would be admissible when you're
trying to scrutinize evidence in
something as serious as getting rid of
the duly elected president the United
States Congress or Matt Gaetz afforda
thanks for joining us tonight appreciate
thank you